[Music]
what i'm going to do now is try to
make a case for why data is so important
in society and actually why the world
would be better if we were actually to
tap into more data and use it for all
the great ways it can be used even
though we need to be extraordinarily
cautious about how we interact with it
because it actually could do some very
dangerous things for us and let me begin
by talking about bloodletting
now
we know that if that if something
happens to us particularly in the era of
covid if we go into a healthcare setting
we can actually be
saved and medical science is indeed a
science and they are going to protect us
by using the best that they can about
empirical evidence to understand how to
treat patients
but you have to ask yourself how was it
possible
that bloodletting was the standard
treatment of care from almost all
ailments
for over 2 000 years there's evidence of
bloodletting in ancient egypt and in
ancient greece
but bloodletting lasted not just through
the middle ages but deep into
he had relatively deep into the 1800s as
well
at the time in which the romantics and
the gothics were writing incredible
literature that we still read today like
mary shelley and frankenstein which sort
of seems to sort of pass the baton to us
or john stewart mill
the standard of care
was to open up people's veins or
arteries
and remove their blood
that's weird
why would that be the case well
they didn't use data
they didn't actually examine it and
understand a lens through
interacting with the world
numer numerically and just to study to
see if it was effective or not
now of course statisticians love
bloodletting because if you actually go
into the advanced statistics classes
you'll see that it's not that
bloodletting
empirically doesn't work there's a lot
of empirical evidence that bloodletting
works it's just not good evidence the
reason is that the people who had their
vein opened and died aren't there to say
it didn't work and everyone who had
their vein opened and survived who
probably would have survived anyway of
course because it didn't actually
benefit the treatment
you know attested to the great benefit
of bloodletting and so that's one reason
why it went on but it took a frenchman
in the 1800s to actually run the numbers
and with the data could say and
demonstrate bloodletting didn't work in
fact was killing patients and eventually
that idea and what they call you know
the numerical method
needed a term like that got rid of
bloodletting so now we can look at
ourselves in 2021 and realize that we're
a society that is wise and doesn't make
such mistakes
[ __ ]
right if you look at the world today
it's just the opposite where else are we
doing the equivalent of bloodletting
thinking that we're doing the right
thing when in fact we've not really
examined it through the lens of data and
in fact we may well be doing the wrong
thing
email marketing campaigns now are all
you know living in the world of data we
see the open rates we see the
click-through rates we test headlines
public policy
policy interventions should we give a
stimulus or not
education what works what doesn't
we are living in a world everywhere we
look
in which it is unexamined through the
lens of information
and why this is such a tragedy is
because we could actually make better
decisions as society if we actually
embrace data and used it as the basis of
our decision making and the good news is
that there's new techniques that enable
us to do things with data that we never
could before that was unfathomable so
let me try to think about this world not
just of data but of when we have big
data and we have more data what we can
do with it let me go quickly through
this
so um this is a cat
we all recognize it as a cat and i know
many of the cynical people here are
thinking yes i've added a picture of a
cat to make everyone feel nice and to
wake you up and to say oh it's great
it's a cat and it's nice
and you would be right
i put this in here only for the purpose
of sort of making you offer happy with
it but there's also another reason why
and that is if we were to define for an
image recognition recognition system
what a cat looks like we would basically
describe the cat through the different
features of it so it has these cute
little whiskers that come out those
almond-shaped eyes right that cute
little nose and that would be a cat but
of course
that's a cat face on i mean you need a
cat from different perspectives to
understand what a cat would look like so
we'd have to actually
make our image recognition system and
define all the rules very intricately
for all the ways in which a cat might
exist and if we actually describe those
rules perfectly a computer will look at
an image of a cat and therefore be able
to define a cat problem it's impossible
to do it's hard to do right but there's
a better way than trying to explicitly
define what a cat is so a computer could
identify a cat in an image recognition
system
instead what we can do is give it lots
of data and if we give the algorithm
if we give the computer system lots and
lots and lots of different examples of
cats some of which are noisy and not
very good at all
it can infer
through this abundance of millions of
examples of cats of all different kinds
of cats of all different angles of
viewing the cat
what a cat looks like in an image and
then it can identify
automatically if the image is looking at
is a cat or not
you can only do that if you have a lot
of data so that the system can make the
inference cat or nocat
let me give a second example which is
sort of the exact same example but in a
different context and that is through
translation if you have used google
translate recently
it has become
absolutely extraordinary it is the i
speak french and english well i speak
english and
my family do not believe i speak french
but i do
um
and uh it is absolutely extraordinary
how good uh the language pairs are and
you can do this for you know 30 40
different language pairs now
and in the past and this is actually the
true computer code but this was hundreds
of doc pages of documents
what was being done in the 1950s was
overtly hand coded trying to get the
word pair in this case of english and
russian to identify which word during
the height of the cold war what one word
in one context meant in another word in
another context and it's hard to do
because of course you don't need you
don't want to just know what is the word
because the word doesn't help you
because lots of words have lots of
different shades of meaning
right and
for example in english we say light and
it could mean illumination but it could
also mean not heavy right and ligea
would work in one context but not in
another
so illuminacion would be the other and
so
the other technique that you would do is
you would just get lots and lots of
examples of translations from one
language and the other and a few of
millions and millions of all the books
that have been translated all the eu
documents that have been translated all
the corporate websites that have been
translated and you have a corpus of a
billion words in french and english you
now can make the world's best translator
right the point is that you had to shift
in your mindset from trying to
explicitly teach the computer the rules
to actually let the computer make an
inference of what the right answer would
be as a huge probability table and what
it takes is data and a lot of data so
that if you will is the big data story
and when we talk about big data what
we're really talking about is machine
learning now it doesn't always have to
be machine learning and there's also new
techniques in which we can tap new data
sources and do new forms of analytics
with it but the machine learning or
artificial intelligence story today that
we're seeing in the press
is largely because these techniques that
are have been around for half a century
are working really really well for two
reasons the first is that we have faster
processors and they're cheaper than ever
and the second and maybe more
importantly
we have more data
okay with more data we improve the
probabilities of our of our inferences
and therefore we have better translation
systems so
what else can we do if we're living in a
world of these inferences that we can
make with more data the first thing we
can do is we can spot signals that we
otherwise would miss
so
google rather microsoft although this is
a google search engine
the microsoft's bing engine several
years ago wanted to identify whether
they could predict whether two drugs
taken together would create an adverse
drug interaction thereby you know
creating a negative problem for
someone's health by taking these two
drugs rather than just
being okay by taking them at the same
time and it turns out through search
engine queries and search engine queries
alone you could do that because when
people are suffering certain forms of
symptoms it leaves sort of a trace and
these symptoms are almost like a
fingerprint for the disease they're
having so if they've searched for one
medication and another medication and a
list of symptoms which basically would
otherwise be background noise unless you
identify
what those drugs would be
you can now identify
earlier than ever in fact identify in a
way that you never otherwise know unless
someone presented to a healthcare clinic
that the person is having an adverse
drug interaction
now the next uh way in which you were
able to you're able to do this let me
actually take a step back and say with
this information you would think that uh
that
that search engines would now be
surveilling
their user population for people who are
identifying these forms of
uh of search queries to know they're
actually having this problem but they're
not doing that they're not allowed to
because of privacy rules this was only
research and you can do it under a
research exemption but you can't do it
in practice so maybe we need to change
that
so the next one is this idea of new
proxies
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you